point I think the answer that is to
raise the minimum wage which we're now
doing so far far far faster than we ever
had done before trained up more
apprenticeships which we're doing on a
scale we've never have done before but
nicer for our talks about remember
history I mean yeah the Faraj family
were foreigners what precise I'm married
to a foreigner you know society of
course I love it but let's be open hard
people generous we control ok it should
no control all I'm saying should we
control it now should I stop bad
immigration but don't pass everybody
with the same brush how girls question
is how do you control immigration as an
EU member be honest with people what we
can and what you sell I true I will tell
exactly the cello which is the freedom
to move around the Europeans should not
be the same as the freedom to claim
that's right yes we if he's not
available it's not about benefit it's
about movement the book your problem is
you seem to apply anyone who's foreigner
comes to this country is a menace when I
sit up we must saying that inner spirit
if we float that - you won't admit the
truth will you the truth is there's
nothing we can do admit